hobb resent us attacks that drove me
pretty nuts and also only kicks off your
liar you're a goddamn liar
since this tax saying hey guys check out
my new Instagram posts bring that [ __ ]
up chin yeah bring it on thing is I can
have sex anymore hold on hold on let's
read it I know well let's read a post I
don't know mmm cuz I want to get into
this yeah me too mmm cuz I think you're
insane
yeah make it easy hey it's his [ __ ]
life you hate something so important -
it also needs better ideas alright
needed better ideas for a while well
rods thing more right here it goes I've
been in constant need of better world
dot dot dot I'm giving up sex period and
definitely definitely now hold on first
of all you 14-thousand be what like this
can suck my dick
it says no my ID I didn't get hacked be
funny if you did
I love sex I'm not an addict to it but I
definitely am but it's a single biggest
thing that is hold me back from serving
my purpose as to causes me to party
spend money catch a cold and waste time
guys call this catch a cold
yeah yeah because stay up and you do
[ __ ] you're not supposed to yeah now
would be Brandon hey hey what dude I'm
gonna hurt you I'm support on the other
front like you did last podcast I'm just
a liar fake I'm here to support my
friend on let's keep reading this uh
I've tried every relationship type
except this one so there's a reason for
that so here we go my goal six months my
rule is I can't receive sexual pleasures
from anyone include take it easy break
and be supportive jackal he's keeping
his diamond I've done this Letty but
let's see how it goes any tips or anyone
out there long as I've got us three
weeks and I had a wet dream at Enid
after eighteen days
look when I hold on hold on first
comment love this brother
I've been stilled
practice deep in my relationship to
myself understand me my connection to
sex several times similarly no sexual
play full stop for me for for me it was
epic guys now look at that support let's
throw him in a flying headlock I want to
do like this guy as he's writing I want
that come out of nowhere
hey get on the ground he put long this
was about 12 months for me however the
body knows how to wet dream or to but it
was out of my hands
you feel me yeah that's a pretty way
you're gonna have some fun and gain
deeper insights into you that's
interesting is it's quite different to
other sorts of the conscious expansion
best of luck with this my man a nice guy
now here's the thing up that's right
that's that guy I've been to the
playground called the onit studios or
whatever the Aubrey studios the Audrey
studios and there isn't a flat ass to be
found and by the way but I don't die or
guess good looking guys and gals I've
ever seen people are working out agree
so enjoy that and good luck I'm
impressed
do you think the Buddha could have been
the Buddha if he didn't live in the
palace and first have all the feasts and
they're small X I like the way I like
you too I'm saying like not have to have
abundance you don't know anyone have
abundance then you can I'm the only
reasonable one here dude Buddhist fat
he's not factored statue you [ __ ]
lose that young man dr. Garth OMA who
became the Buddha which means the
enlightened one was in life was not Kido
poor man he looked food ha he loved food
he indulged in food so it wasn't that
discipline well no no he did live on a
cup of rice tried today because no I got
an any moderation so he ate some
moderation wasn't strategy ate all that
wasn't shredded all the food God know
that you don't know that this isn't
about Union I support him hurt you
support him fine where did this come
from okay so this there's a couple
different things one if I can open
relations
for one is an amazing thing that I think
everybody should try but it will it's
almost guaranteed not to work but it's
worth it that's important to dial it on
for a second it's [ __ ] really dry
worth it I tried like really hard
doesn't work and I think you've learned
a lot about yourself and you grow and
you become a better person but the
problem is is that it's almost
impossible to execute continually
because the thing is is that novelty of
the new person creates this thing what
the science calls limerence which is
this new relationship energy where you
become temporarily obsessed with the new
person that you're seeing for you so
you're in this relationship with someone
that you love dearly and then they find
somebody else it's not just called
asking obsessed with them right and that
thing is almost impossible it's it is
you take almost how that sounds yeah so
like no matter how much you know how
much love you share how long you've been
with them like they'll find some new
person and that new person whoever that
is will be the obsession of their mind
of their body of their life for a little
while and I've been the person who've
been obsessed and then my partner's been
the person who's been obsessed
so that thing in and of itself is almost
impossible to transcend and I think it
is possible but you have to get to such
a state I don't know why it's imagined
all these egos yeah you know I'm saying
there is a possibility to be committed
to the person but then to say I'm not
gonna try to control that person's
behavior in any way like sort of like
it's sort of like whatever you do you're
gonna do and I can't stop you anyway so
whatever fulfills you but there's a way
to sort of well don't see all this right
though yeah I don't want be with anyone
who's gonna be [ __ ] dudes on the road
right do you but also don't [ __ ] your
video but yeah but also you talk about
swingers that usually works no no I'm
just talking about I'm just I'm up being
in a situation where you try not to
control someone's behavior right I don't
think you should I don't think you
should own someone sexuality but the
problem is when you open the door to
sexuality you open the door to this
thing which is this mental obsession
with the new it's not
I think I think it's I think there's a
biology to it right I agree I think that
we evolved to the fact that you do catch
diseases if you're not careful and I
think there's an there's an inherent
intuitive natural need for possession
because it's very dangerous Tora Klee
was very dangerous for your pardon to go
off because well not only they might go
off and shack up and leave you with the
children you can't provide for them you
starve to death during the winter or
whatever it might they might get a
disease and bring it back to you there's
so many there's so many physical dangers
traditionally historically that we're
always clear and present and I feel like
that's also part of our deal especially
in a man's DNA isn't it it's in our DNA
to spread our see that's also true but
the in certain tribal settings right
where you have a tribe underneath the
Dunbar number of 150 right which is
about how tribes split up yeah within
that tribe it was more about tribe
survival than singular survival numbers
explain that - it's a really cool yeah
after that yeah yeah the Dunbar number
is basically the amount of people that
you can give a [ __ ] about yes at any
given time it's about one yes it's about
150 give or take right so tribes always
split - about that amount but when the
tribe was more important than the
singular individual which is I think how
we're actually designed and I think it's
a big problem that we have right now is
we don't have that sense of community
but within that you see structures of
relationship where people didn't really
care about who the father was or what
the what the dyad what didn't what the
couple bond was because it was all about
the survival of the tribe itself but
however if someone went outside of the
tribe
well that was [ __ ] war yeah because I
don't give a [ __ ] about anybody outside
of your Dunbar number the problem with
open relationship now is it's not within
your tribe it's not the people you love
yeah way easier when it's someone you
love I've been in that situation where
someone I'm with is with somebody I love
and it's actually really chill I
actually to be completely honest that's
like a guy like both of you guys but
especially like a dude like him or like
if if my girl if I all [ __ ] aside my
girl wanted to like step out with my boy
wear my bra I'll be like you know it
wouldn't
with me the same it was way better but
when it's some [ __ ] I think when it's
some [ __ ] yeah who let me die some
you touch my girl did a man it could be
heavy eyes
what name a night
why does my son look like my son so
you're cool with it I guess I'm a man do
you heard it I guess I am yeah but so
this song you went down such a you went
you went so hard in the paint on the
siliceous so hard in the paint and the
problem is it wasn't within the tribe it
was these random [ __ ] Yahoo's yeah I
didn't even know yeah it didn't
contribute
yeah just coming in and then the my
partner would be obsessed with with that
the first boy the new the new thing and
I didn't know this [ __ ] so he
was in my DNA he was outside of the
tribe so my inclination is not to be
like oh that's my brother and we're all
in this thing together we're all
supporting each other we're all helping
us to yeah better it's like no he's
[ __ ] taking something that's mine and
I want to stab him in the throat I tell
me that one thing that haunted me I was
haunting I was like - I was backed up
yeah
haunting alright so anyways but through
that process there's also a lot of
beauty a lot of growth and a lot of
experience for me and I got - I've
obviously got to experience an abundance
of my own sexual adventures women in the
world
let's also sink you'd rather I
appreciate that they are beautiful women
and beautiful in a lot of ways you know
and yeah and I got to experience this
kind of level of abundance and in truth
in that as well like I never had to hide
anything and I was free to just do
whatever I like but nonetheless so it
was a combination of abundance plus the
combination of those repeated just
punches in the gut from the people that
I eventually you know always had
feelings for getting obsessed with other
people that so that whole thing was like
I needed to kind of put a stop to that
whole adventure and that was one of the
reasons why I was like wow I really want
to I really want to take a break where
I'm not actually even available or open
to these type of sexual connections
because I need to give myself a [ __ ]
just a [ __ ] breather yeah you know
it's just like taking a break from spar
you're just like I got I might have CTE
yeah in my [ __ ] yep in my inside me
you know I think you're addicted to it
I'm sure I like some of the drama and
the swings and the up-and-down like
that's like a it's an endogenous
chemical cocktail that comes in you feel
those feel those things and you and also
the competition right because I'm always
competing to be the best dick be the one
that [ __ ] them the best and then get
their attention back oh you have
attention to this other guy well let me
show you how [ __ ] bad I am and you'll
[ __ ] forget about them but they don't
forget about them but you keep trying
you keep reaching that's it it is it's
very exciting but it makes your dick a
little harder to no doubt it's called
reclamation sex so they come back from
this other guy and you're there with
them and you're like who while you were
with this other guy well watch this time
for some punishment a remark his
territory now that guy's got a bigger
dick I'm gonna crawl in the corner and
cry but the point is this I'm trying to
get in their head whatever whatever
whatever it takes so it was not only
what I'm what I'm basically telling you
is this took so much time and energy and
effort not only in the in the
maintenance of things but in the
competition of things in an emotional
reconciliation it became party right
quality work I'm actually shocked that I
accomplished anything over the last six
years it's really actually remarkable
yeah but I was able to do anything yeah
because the amount of energy expenditure
I had was just out of control
so finally like I knew I knew at some
point I had to hit pause to like get
everything reconciled in an order an
interesting that you talk this way
because if you think of any of the great
wisdoms any philosophy I don't I've read
a lot of philosophy I've read a lot
about religions I've read most of the
main major manuscripts and religion I
don't know of a religion I don't know of
a philosophy that can hold water that
advocates maybe you could marinate the
Armand with Nietzsche but for the most
part they all advocate some form of self
restriction some form a lot of it's not
yeah if not if not monogamy certainly
certainly will never
sexual conservatism to an extent right
because they can't encourage your when
she's gone but there's a deeper there's
a deeper truth to it which is you made a
lot of these guys whether it was Thomas
Aquinas whether it was who wrote
confessions please look up confessions
uh I'm sorry it's a very important book
but a lot of people who went off and did
that came back to Augustine st.
Augustine one of the founders of the
church McCain back to sort of a deeper
purity a deeper kind of conservatism it
feels like that's kind of where you're
headed I think it's interesting that
most people that go that direction if
they're honest which you are will
chamber hold my beer and champion
no but that's that's true but maybe
every celebrity I know if sports wino
goes I'm gay but you know what a lot of
celebrities do it I've noticed too is
that they go crazy and then they're in a
a lot of that this town is so full of
sober pure for now because they went so
crazy but it's a similar pleasure
principle I feel like but the bottom
line is that a lot of people you get
older you start to try it you try to
start a circle back to and you
understand why these wisdoms advocate
that whether it's yoga whether it's
Buddhism whether it's Catholicism
whether it I have to believe that since
they're still relevant and they have a
lot to offer that there's some deep
wisdom there I don't think you I think
one of the things that they don't talk
about which is a failure is I think you
have to actually get to abundance before
you can let it go there you go right
like a lot of people I think maybe a lot
of people who are talking about these
you know path of restrictions and this
you know path of abstaining from this
thing and that maybe couldn't get that
like whoa let's let's not worry about
wealth well they couldn't get wealthy so
they just made it like oh you don't need
that so it wasn't real because if they
actually had the chance to get wealthy
they would I don't think you can
transcend the desire for wealth unless
you're wealthy I don't think you can
transcend the desire for success unless
you've been successful and I don't think
you can let go of sex unless you've had
a radical abundance of sex yeah to the
point where you can be like okay okay
okay like I got this you know what it is
I know what it is and I felt it I've
experienced all the things I can let it
go I'm not letting it go forever it
sounds like you though we're talking
about this different so in the Bible of
just to take
it's not the love of money that's
through it of all evil its I'm sorry
it's not the money that's rid of all the
actual quarters it's the love of money
hmm so you know you were being
controlled a little bit it was taking up
a large part of your psyche and your
energy did you hit rock bottom um [ __ ]
you would be wrong about I [ __ ] got
dribbled off that like I was a [ __ ]
basketball that you would be lying down
girl that's well that was the highs
right so if you imagine a basketball
bouncing off rock bottom and then going
up flying up sky or maybe one of those
super bouncy balls right so these are
super super high the lows are super low
cuz it is you find that new person you
have this new experience and it is the
chase and the thrill and even with the
same person you get these super highs of
Reclamation and wow this is so
incredible we're back together like
everything feels electric and alive and
then you get the super lows so it's this
it's this bounce of fact no that was
just kind of constant instead of this
just general band of equanimity and
means we're like ah now let me look at
what I can do in my life that actually
is going to be the most productive
almost letting things come to you maybe
yeah in in and also I think this for me
is just like this is just a little bit
of a hard stop no [ __ ] way I'm gonna
give up sex know what he did for a long
time but like my goal is six months I
got a book manuscript do then that takes
a lot of time anyways dude one step at
one day at a time one time five days to
do today
listen I'm five days it we don't talk to
him but here we do six months let's get
through Sunday and they get from I can
six months it's like you're bill you're
going at the top of the mountain
climbing average drawing at the top of
the mountain no let's get the take up
steps
have some tea couple biscuits talk talk
still feel good still feel good line the
next little bit more like that you just
went
well that's why I said my goal right you
know and I said indefinitely I don't
know exactly when it's my goal is
roughly six months I don't know don't
look up but Thursday here's a question I
have for you guys so my rule that I put
out is I'm not going to have sexual
pleasure for myself but I'm wondering if
I can still have hope people sit on my
face no hey
no you can't the answer he answered me
is well the answer to me is 100% but I
thought I would say wafers you guys do
it you got to just get away from all of
it because you're still suits kind of in
the hustle over Dixon basically the
question is can I have one and only four
classes if not there's no way a girl
sitting on my face and I'm not gonna
have to have sex we're still in the pool
bro fool get out of the pool see I
didn't want to hear that answer but I
think you're right bro / you're a girl
that night right you came in jack off
get out the people read oh she's gonna
reach for your piece and she's gonna go
let me put in my mouth and then you're
gonna go okay but I'm not gonna come
next week me I'm only gonna come in
their mouth that's not in the bargaining
starts and then the gradual slide dude
get out the pool yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]